it may not have affected the outcome of
the 2016 election but the Russians were
able to pull off a wide-ranging
aggressive and brazen attempt to
interfere in the campaign so can our
intelligence agencies stop them from
doing it again let's ask an old friend
former CIA director Jim Woolsey Jim it's
great to have you on thanks for being
here tonight
this wilds I mean this indictment today
it was wild I mean they were organizing
all sorts of things they were they were
working for that Jill Stein trying to
help her they were they were anti-trump
and pro-trump on one day after the
election what's that all about they want
to be a force and they want to disrupt
things they call their big overall
program design for motsi disinformation
and they've been doing this since the
1920's 1930's what's new is that they do
it with cyber but they haven't didn't
have much luck disrupting American
elections back in you know 1930s or
1940s but they've been doing that to
other countries all along
Ian Maihi p'chepo the head of Romanian
intelligence who defected in 79 says
that there are more Russians involved in
disinformation than there are in their
Armed Forces how about the Chinese Jim
what do they do to try to disrupting a
lot of things around the world for us I
know so far not the same way the
Russians do
but the Russians know they photoshopped
photographs of the Pope to make him look
like he's saluting to a German Nazi
officer they just you don't think the
Chinese are involved in this type of
activity we may have an economy that
Dwarfs Russia's their standing army of
2.3 million people their militarizing
space stealing our technology I mean I
think it's important that we stop this
Russian stuff but every time someone
says Russia Russia Russia Russia
I say China China oh you should it's
that's right that they are strategically
a lot smarter
the Russians basically are like the old
fellow lived next to the Lincoln's in
their farm when he was a little boy like
considered the old boy used to say I
don't need much land just what a joins
mine that's Russia I mean I got some
George oh let's take some Ukraine and
that's pretty much economies smaller
than the size of
France I mean they're they don't I mean
come on compared to China I mean China's
like eating our lunch on so many fried
it down and it gives us some leverage if
we can work to get the price of oil down
and 30s well 40s even we will create a
very very unhappy but we don't want it
we don't want to push Russia to China
though that's the last thing I want is a
Russo sino Alliance a weaken them
because we can deal with them a lot
better if they're weak I was negotiating
the conventional forces treaty Europe in
70 in 89 when they the Berlin Wall went
down and you've never seen such nice
Russians let me tell you all you got to
do is destroy their strategy they're
sweethearts but is it Trump doing that
with pushing all this domestic energy
production we're we are soon gonna
become the largest exporter of energy in
the world doesn't that isn't that a
weapon against Russian expansionism it's
good but it's really mainly about a
balance of payments what matters more is
the price if you can get the price not
up there in the 70s and 80s but down in
the 30s and 40s and you can do it just
by letting a lot we have a lot of energy
being produced with fracking and
everything else yeah that helps but you
can also to get the price down you can
give people an incentive to have two
fuels to choose from at the pump filling
station and once you do that you've got
arbitrage that takes the price of oil
down into the 30s or 40s and they're
about that the rush about that Obama
didn't do much in response to this
process meddling in our election they
knew back in 2014
long before Trump got into the mix that
this was a problem but what I mean that
far as I could tell they just allowed
that uranium one sale to go through with
that cepheus committee yeah so that that
helped Russia
sure sure what do we do how do we stop
this in the future we can weaken them
economically and then what I think what
we really want is to get them to start
pulling in their horns and coming back
out of Georgia back out of Ukraine we we
need them we need to turn them around
because they are taking over
with their military and other
inadequacies they are taking over a lot
more of eurasia than they should and it
gives them heart as they take more and
more under their wings have we ever
tried to meddle in other countries
elections Oh probably but it was for the
good of the system in order to avoid the
Communists from taking over for example
in Europe in 47 48 49 the Greeks and the
Italians we only for a very good do a
vine video and as former CIA totally for
a very good cause out interest of
democracy thanks for being here it's
always great to see you